recebi essa pergunta do Instagram e vou
tentar respondê-la de uma maneira que
seja mais útil possível pro maior número
possível de pessoas. Os diversos tipos
de magnésio tem alguma raiz em comum ou
são nutrientes diferentes? Bem, sabe
aquele comprimido de magnésio que você
compra na farmácia achando que está
fazendo um grande investimento na sua
saúde? Pois é, meu amigo, minha amiga,
tem uma chance absurda de você estar
literalmente jogando dinheiro no vaso
sanitário. Olha só que coisa
impressionante. Um estudo publicado em
2024 no Frontiers em Endocrinology
mostrou que o óxido de magnésio, aquele
que 90% dos médicos presescrevem porque
é baratinho, tem 60% de magnésio
elementar, mas seu intestino só consegue
absorver míseros 4%.
É como comprar um saco de 10 kg de arroz
e só conseguir comer 400 g. E o resto,
pessoal, vai embora na descarga. Deixa
eu te contar uma história que aconteceu
no meu consultório semana passada. Uma
paciente chegou frustrada, tomando
magnésio faz seis meses, sem melhorar
nada das câras. Quando olhei a receita
era óxido de magnésio 500 mg. Expliquei
para ela. Olha, dona Maria, a senhora tá
tomando 300 mg de magnésio elementar por
dia, mas seu corpo tá aproveitando só 12
mg. É como tomar homeopatia sem querer.
Mudamos para glicinato e magnésio e em
duas semanas as câbras sumiram. Sabe por
quê? A biodisponibilidade faz toda a
diferença e isso é algo que a abordagem
funcional sempre considera. Existem pelo
menos 10 tipos diferentes de magnésios
no mercado e cada um tem uma função
específica no seu organismo. É tipo
escolher ferramenta numa caixa de
ferramenta. Você não vai usar martelo
para apertar parafuso, né? O magnésio
cetrato, por exemplo, tem excelente
absorção intestinal, segundo estudos de
2021 publicados no Journal of Trace
Elements. É o queridinho para quem tem
prisão de ventre, porque tem um efeito
laxativo suave. Eu já vi paciente que
resolveu dois problemas de uma vez só.
Melhorou o magnésio sérico e ainda
regularizou o intestino que funcionava a
cada três dias. Mas espera aí que a
coisa fica mais interessante ainda. O
magnésio glicinato é o rei da tolerância
gastrointestinal. Pesquisas recentes
2024 mostram que ele combina magnésio
com glicina, um aminoácido que por si só
tem propriedades calmantes. É aquele
dois em um que a gente adora, sabe?
A glicina ajuda na qualidade do sono e o
magnésio relaxa a musculatura.
Prescrevo muito para paciente ansioso
que reclama de insônia. Agora segura
essa bomba. Existe um magnésio que
literalmente entra no seu cérebro. O
elitrionato de magnésio, que é
desenvolvido pelo IMIT, é o único que
comprovadamente
atravessa a barreira emoencefálica.
Um estudo chinês 2022 com 109 adultos
saudáveis mostrou melhora significativa
em todas as cinco subcategorias de teste
memória. Após só 30 dias de
suplementação, os pesquisadores mediram
um aumento de 54%
nos níveis de magnésio no líquido céfalo
rakidiano. Para você ter ideia, isso é
revolucionário na visão integrativa do
envelhecimento cerebral. Teve um caso no
consultório que me marcou demais. Uma
senhora de 68 anos, professora
aposentada, chegou preocupada com lapsos
de memória. Doutor, tu dis queci onde
estacionei o carro no shopping. Fiquei
uma hora procurando. Fizemos exames,
magnésio cérico estava normal, mas isso
não significa nada pro cérebro.
então elitronato de magnésio 2 g por
dia. 3 meses depois ela votou radiante.
Tô lembrando até do nome dos alunos de
20 anos atrás. É isso que os estudos
mostram. O eletrireonato pode reverter
até 9 anos de envelhecimento cerebral em
termos cognitivos. O magnésio malato é
outro que merece atenção especial. Ele
combina magnésio com ácido málico,
fundamental no ciclo de crebes paraa
produção de ATP.
Sabe aquele paciente que reclama de
fadiga crônica, que acorda cansado mesmo
dormindo 8 horas? É para esse que eu
mando malato de magnésio. A literatura
científica de 2024 confirma que essa
forma é excelente para quem tem
fibromialgia ou síndrome de fadiga
crônica. Eu lembro de uma enfermeira que
atendia no CTI e vivia exausta, três
semanas de malato de magnésio. E ela me
disse: "Doutor, parece que trocaram
minha bateria". E o cloreto de magnésio,
viu? Esse é o palpor da obra. Barato,
eficiente, com absorção decente de cerca
de 12% do magnésio elementar. É o que eu
chamo de magnésio do trabalhador. Não é
o mais sofisticado, mas resolve o
problema sem quebrar o orçamento. Uso
muito em protocolo de reposição inicial
quando o paciente tá com deficiência
severa e precisa repor rápido sem gastar
uma fortuna. Tem paciente que gasta R$
200 suplemento importado quando podia
resolver com R$ 30 de clorite magnésio.
Mas olha só que curioso, o sulfato de
magnésio, aquele famoso sal amargo, o
sal de épson, é o protocolo padrão
hospitalar para eclâmpsia e
pré-eclâmpsia. Quando administrado
endovenoso, salva vidas literalmente,
mas oral é péssima absorção, causa
diarreia que você pensa que vai virar do
avesso. Já o magnésio taurato combinado
com taurina é excelente para saúde
cardiovascular, segundo metaanálises
recentes. Passa de hipertenso, ou seja,
com pressão alta e arritmia tá orato
nele. Agora vou te contar um segredo que
poucos médicos sabem.
A forma do magnésio influencia até onde
ele vai se acumular no seu corpo.
Estudos com marcadores radioativos
mostram que o citrato tem preferência
pelos inslicinato pelos músculos e o
elitronato pelo tecido nervoso. É tipo
GPS molecular. Cada forma sabe para onde
ir. Por isso que na abordagem
integrativa a gente personaliza atleta
com câimbra, glicinato ou bisglicinato.
Idoso com declíneo cognitivo,
elitrionato sem pensar duas vezes. A
dose também é fundamental. A
recomendação de área é de 400 mg de
magnésio elementar para homens e 310
para mulheres. Mas presta atenção, isso
é de magnésio elementar, não do composto
total. Se o rótulo óxido de magnésio 500
mg, você tá tomando só 300 mg de
magnésio alimentar e com absorção de 4%
sobram ridículos 12 mg pro seu corpo. É
matemática básica que a indústria
farmacêutica não quer que você saiba.
Uma coisa que eu aprendi nesses anos
todos de prática, time é tudo. Magnésio
compete com caos pela absorção. Então
nunca prescrevo os dois juntos. Ferro
também atrapalha. O ideal é tomar
magnésio à noite, longe das refeições
principais.
Exceção, se trato de magnésio pode ser
tomado comida se causar desconforto
gástrico.
E aquela história de que magnésio tem
que ser quelado para absorver bem, meia
verdade, queelação ajuda, mas não é
garantia. O que importa é a solubilidade
em pH intestinal. Sabe o que mais me
impressiona? Dados recentes mostram que
65%
dos americanos não consome magnésio
suficiente na dieta. No Brasil não temos
estatística confiável, mas aposto que é
pior. Solo empobrecido, alimentos
processados, estresse crônico, que
depleta o magnésio, é uma tempestade
perfeita pra deficiência. E o pior,
exame de sangue comum não detecta
deficiência de magnésio. E por quê?
Porque 99% magnésio tá dentro das
células e não no sangue. É como medir o
nível de gasolina olhando o tanque de
reserva. Eu vou te dar uma dica de ouro
agora. Se você tem síndrome do intestino
irritável, evite óxido ou citrato de
magnésio. Vai piorar os seus sintomas.
Prefira glicinato ou elitrionato. Se tem
doença renal, cuidado com qualquer forma
de magnésio, os rins que eliminam
excesso. Você é diabético, magnésio
melhora a sensibilidade insulina, mas
monitora a glicose porque pode
potencializar os medicamentos. São
detalhes que fazem diferença entre
sucesso e fracasso no tratamento. E aqui
vai a observação importante da minha
prática clínica. Magnésio transdérmico,
aqueles sprays e óleos que vendem por
aí. A ciência ainda é controversa.
Alguns estudos pequenos sugerem
absorção, outros não conseguem
comprovar. Então eu uso em atletas para
recuperação muscular localizada, uso em
crianças, mas não como reposição
sistêmica principal. Então é
complementar, nunca substituto da
suplementação oral bem feita. Agora,
falando em evidências científicas
sólidas, um estudo de 2024 publicado no
Sleep Medicine mostrou que o
elitrireonato de magnésio melhorou
significativamente a qualidade do sono
em função de urna em adultos com
problemas de sono autorelatados. Os
participantes tomaram apenas 1 g por dia
durante 21 dias. Imagina só três semanas
para melhorar algo que muita gente sofre
há anos. É por isso que a visão
integrativa valoriza tanto a nutrição
funcional. pequenas mudanças e grandes
resultados. Então, deixa te contar uma
coisa fascinante. Pesquisadores
descobriram que o magnésio elitrionato
pode modular o eixo microbiota intestino
cérebro. Um estudo 2024 mostrou que essa
forma específica de magnésio alterou a
composição da microbiota intestinal,
aumentando o bifobactérias benéficas e
reduzindo bactérias inflamatórias. Ou
seja, além de melhorar a cognição
diretamente, ele ainda arruma o seu
intestino. É o que chamo de bala de
prata nutricional. Atira em vários alvos
ao mesmo tempo. E para finalizar, eu vou
ser direto e reto com você. Se você tá
tomando magnésio e não vê resultado,
provavelmente tá tomando o tipo errado,
na dose errada ou no horário errado. Não
é falta de magnésio no seu corpo, é
falta de conhecimento sobre qual
magnésio seu corpo precisa. Na minha
experiência clínica, quando acertamos a
forma, a dose, o timing, os resultados
aparecem duas a quatro semanas, às vezes
até antes.
Saia do vídeo agora se você gosta de
ficar no superficial. Eu vou te contar
uma verdade inconveniente. O YouTube e o
conselho de medicina me limitam. Aqui
preciso de simplificar, censurar
dosagens, omitir protocolos
controversos. Na comunidade fechada não
tem filtro. Compartilha os exatos
protocolos que eu uso na minha clínica.
Caso de reversão que parecem
impossíveis, combinações ofel que
funcionam, fornecedores confiáveis,
interpretação avançada de exames. É
basicamente ter acesso ao meu cérebro
médico sem intermediários. Live semanais
respondendo perguntas, PDF com 47
protocolos exclusivos e grupo no
WhatsApp. Se você quer medicina
funcional real, sem simplificação para
as massas, clique em seja membro. Não é
para curiosos, é para quem quer
resultados.